should be live here.
Let me set the category.
We're doing something a little different
today. Um,
just let me show real quick.
So, we got this working.
1.6 second breakout training. Hey, Brad.
Um, I've been working on this all day.
I'm going to take a little break. Uh, I
figured I'd just try some net hack and
stream it since we're doing a project
trying to learn Net Hack. Or rather, I I
stuck Finn on this. Uh, I played this a
little bit like 10 years ago. I've
watched a fair bit of content
surrounding the game and read up quite a
bit on it because it's just such an
awesome really sim is what it is. A
really awesome sim. It's an awesome
environment for RL and just a really
cool game. So, since uh Finn is working
on this, I figured I'd get a little bit
more knowledge of the game so I can
understand where and why the agent might
get be getting stuck. And also, I
figured it would just be fun to stream
this.
I'm going to do a short stream, maybe
hour, hour and a half, something like
that.
And um we are just going to see
how this goes.
No,
we're going to play
easy mode.
Okay, I This is just the tips are being
like my settings are weird, but it's
fine. Ah, numpad. That's why. Hang on.
Numpad off.
Don't you think we need a better
algorithm to make use of data? We do as
well. If you check X, we have a bunch of
articles with um all of the improvements
we've made. Actually, look at this.
In Puffer 5C, which is the dev branch
I've been working on, all of our fancy
new algorithm stuff is right here.
Here's our infrastructure, and then we
have surrounding tools and stuff.
brown potion
and a noot.
but presumably this is
yeah this way.
Oh, yeah. What did I start with?
Borvish spear.
I actually haven't been able to figure
this out. I'm playing on um on a server
here. I thought Valk started with a long
sword.
I don't know why I have a spear.
When did this game come out? Like was it
1987 or something? I don't know. It says
it in the Twitch title,
but it's been under active development
for a very long time.
Okay, low boots and of course the
fountain.
Okay, so these are uncursed because my
kitten walked on them.
Right. So, I should be able to
wear
What the heck are these dumb Twitch
bots?
Door is locked.
Hello. Welcome.
zombie.
I think I can just kill that, right?
You should have the wiki open on the
side.
candy bars.
A grave.
Yeah, we're playing some Net Hack. I'm
taking a little break.
Oh, yeah. Jess, um 1.6 second breakout.
Yeah, this could very easily kill me if
I mess with that.
We'll just leave that alone.
Oh, I did not mean to move, but
whatever.
I thought you could pry stuff with your
dagger. No.
Oh, actually I don't even I didn't even
try to open it, right?
Uh, I don't want to. Okay, I should have
wielded the dagger.
Right. I don't want to be messing that
with my spear.
You didn't break it, right?
Yeah. Whoops.
I played I did one for context. I played
one run of this over the last two days
and that was my first game in 10 years.
Kick it. You can break potions though,
right?
Okay. So, we'll just take everything
right.
No, I'll push it a couple times just for
the hell of it.
Forcing can break your slashing weapon.
Yeah. So, it's not great to lose the
dagger.
You will get a ton more of those, right?
So, I'd prefer to have something to
throw for the first level or two. Grid
bug.
So, the tragedy of yesterday was uh I
accidentally blew up my dog on the
second level
and I couldn't curse ID anything
reasonably because of that.
I made it to level 9 and then died like
messing around on the earlier levels
trying to find a new dog or cat.
We got a fox.
Uh, these things hurt level one, don't
they?
Nope. Apparently not.
Apparently, it just dies.
I can just shove. Uh, hang on. If I
shove this, do I Yeah, I block it.
I go around.
This is where I started.
Did not check this way though.
Possibly missed a room.
Huh? I searched like 20 times.
That's weird.
Presumably there is something there.
It's just a dead end is kind of weird.
No.
might be closest.
Still an opening on level five.
on the east.
Oh, I did miss that. Thank you.
I think you can eat this thing, which is
fine.
Ah, and I I don't know how I missed two
entrances, but that would make a lot
more sense.
Oh, I left my uh my cat. Hang on. My
whatever.
Okay,
been a few extra turns, but whatever.
We got level two.
A little bit more comfortable.
Let's see
we can find any early equipment
because this time I did not kill my pet.
I
I'm going to kill this close so that my
pet doesn't try to eat it.
No meat that will ignore it. Ah, okay.
Didn't know that.
Diagonals are a little awkward as well
if you uh see me moving straight when
it's not absolutely necessary because
this keyboard does not have a numpad.
Scroll.
Hello, Ryan.
I died to um
alter. Oh,
interesting.
Yeah, I died yesterday due to
polymorphing two elves into a
naga a guardian naga and a vampire lord.
Does that even help me though? Can't I
just like Don't I get the same thing out
of just seeing what my pet walks on.
Not killing the pet. I need the pet for.
Um that's basically why I lost the last
game was no pet.
I didn't find a single altar, so I had
no way to test anything. So, I was just
[ __ ] AC.
That will not tell you blessed/
uncursed, just cursed or not.
Uh, okay, fair.
It will tell me if I can put the damn
thing on.
What? I don't even have anything to test
though, right?
A is G. Wait, A
uh armor
Spell book, scrolls, potions. Oh, okay.
So, control D. Control D is kick on
mine.
Shift D.
Okay. And then we'll just do
items of unknown. Okay, that's good.
Thank you.
Wait,
the food is not going to be.
We just do this. This this
f e k l.
brilliant blue potion.
Black for lash
plus blue potion.
Okay. Yeah, the key scheme for this is
actually quite easy for me to navigate
relatively quickly because BIM
first dark green gem. Cool. So, we pick
everything back up.
I can still pick up the curve potion and
do whatever with it, right?
You can use Yubn for diagonals, and I do
when I need it to attack, but if you
don't need to, it's actually pretty
awkward to reach over for those.
Yeah, we can just pick up everything.
So, we just do A B C D E F G H.
Got my boots back. Cool. Now we can
always bring this.
Uh, no, it's not easy.
It's kind of awkward still. Like it's
not
HJ KL is natural from Vim. That's like
very very natural. The diagonals are not
natural at all. Like I have to actively
look down.
This is going to mess up the boulder.
We'll just leave that for a second.
That's how I play normally. I do use
them,
but it doesn't really matter to save
turns not under duress too much.
Like most of the hunger and stuff you
lose is from spending 20 turns searching
or whatever.
3D.
Uh, no. That looks interesting though.
What's here? Just this. Shove. Shove.
Shove. Shove. Shove. Shove. Shove.
Shove. Shove.
Let's just see if there's anything up
top.
Y is especially just awkward to reach
for the diagonals.
Okay. Eat something.
Uh this maybe
what are these
jackals on level two?
That looks fine to me for this level. We
know there's an altar here.
What is star?
Star is a gem.
Ooh,
that's nice.
We got stealth,
huh?
I think I can just face tank this.
Yeah.
Okay. Let's [sighs and gasps]
large box.
Locked
open.
Actually, is it force?
Actually, no. Wait, we need to wield
the dagger.
Yes.
Force. Whoops.
Force.
Yes.
Field.
here.
Okay.
See what's in here. Read me. And an
orange gem.
Is that a like a joke or is that
actually safe to read?
Dagger. not cursed.
Did we not know that already from uh
I don't think that could have been
cursed from the altar, right?
Oh, actually,
let's take the money.
I thought we knew. Wait, can your
starter equipment be cursed?
scroll and a
potion.
There's the door.
This statue of a noot.
A short sword.
Um
A
cursed short sword.
I think I will leave that alone. Right.
Yeah, cursed short sword.
Oh, what's that? Is that a wear? No,
giant rat
here.
Oh, cool.
Kills it.
I see why you lose the why you like just
die randomly, man.
Um,
Oh,
well. Um,
stop.
Let's see what we have in here.
A peaceful whatever the hell.
A ga wait. A gaspore.
What?
Is this a
This is how I killed my um my pet last
time.
Ring mail. I don't have enough for that.
Purple
red potion.
Deitar. Is this Runescape
We might come back for the armor.
That's expensive though.
Doesn't super help. Right. Blindfold is
nice.
Is the kitten going to attack a gas
pore? Is it that dumb?
No.
Wait,
what is happening here? I don't want to
repeat.
Well, this specific thing. Yeah.
Okay.
My kitten is not here,
right?
What is wrong with my freaking cat?
Why does it not?
Is it just like Is it focused on some
food or something here? Key scimitar.
No.
There's a Reddit post from three months
ago.
Okay, we'll finish wandering around. Oh,
now it follows. It wouldn't follow me
before for some reason.
There.
We're fine.
That was weird.
Uh there's no other
discernable entries.
We're going to go
just really quick. Oops.
This large red mold.
Now we don't care about that.
Going to real quick go back to um
hello.
It's lost.
This is not an impatient game.
All right. What did was I told to do?
So, drop
shift D
X.
Oh, we got some information out of that,
right?
Plus scroll best plus potion.
Right.
And we can just go to the
next floor.
hit it, right?
My [ __ ] cat's going to hit it.
Lovely.
time of Yeah, that's the shop thing.
Okay, cool. So, no resistance.
Coyote
named coyote.
Oh, it's an Easter egg. It's a normal
coyote.
N corpse padded gloves.
Okay, let's eat this.
Oh, wait. I wasn't
Maybe those aren't safe to eat. I
forget. Is that hallucinogen?
We still need to deal with.
Well, let's deal with this coyote first.
What's the with the AI on this stupid
thing?
The kitten drops a pair of padded
gloves.
Okay. So, that's got to be safe then,
right?
If it picks them up.
huh? Gauntlets of power.
Well,
that's kind of cool.
That helps a lot, huh?
Now, if we can just get our AC to
something more reasonable.
Let me turn the uh the arrow on. One
sec.
Plus
seven strength
and gauntlets of power. Huh,
that's crazy. I don't actually know how
the damage calcs work. Is it similar to
DN D?
But this is going to be quite
broken.
AD and D. Gotcha.
So yeah, 25 strength is batshit.
Yo, cat, get over here.
Good.
You are right that the pets are
annoying, Ryan, but
incredibly useful.
for curse test. I wouldn't have put
those gauntlets on otherwise.
I would have just sat with them. And if
I didn't find an altar, I would have
just not had this crazy bonus.
Why does the kitten bite the [ __ ]
gnome?
All right, the kitten kills and eats the
gnome.
Very cool.
Well,
new moon wear jackal changes into a
human
and it dies in one hit. Thank you very
much. 25 strength.
That's basically it.
I'm fine just going deeper from here.
Now my cat's here.
Where is the
What is
remembered unseen creature?
I don't know how easy it is to kill my
uh my pet,
but I'd rather not find out.
That was the main issue I had last game.
As long as I have the pet
Wait. Ruined arrows
and another chest.
Wait, what did it say? A trapped lock
chest.
Arm.
How do you disarm? It's untrappp, right?
And it's locked.
Oops.
Build this.
Where's this?
It's empty.
Lovely.
Let's not screw up this boulder.
Come back to this side.
We still have not gotten any resistances
at level five.
That's a little concerning to me.
Okay, there's nothing else there. Cool.
Actually, wait. Can I push it this way?
No,
I don't even know. Can't I get decks
from uh
counting gold. So, there's a shop here
somewhere.
Um,
probably up here.
What's this spell book?
Cool. We missed a shop though, right?
You hear somebody counting coins? means
there's a shop, right?
Um I mean the obvious place for a shop
on this level would be
I don't really have much gold for it to
even matter to be honest.
But
what's this food ration? Oh yeah, we
forgot the food ration. Just take this.
Oops. I uh kicked empty air.
Oh, wait. My decks went up to nine. So,
I guess from kicking all the doors, I
actually got a point in decks.
That is nice.
I have some food.
I'm not too worried about food yet,
but it probably isn't like particularly
helpful anyways.
We'll just go.
No big deal.
Getting Where's my
Where's the stupid cat? There it is.
Come on.
See, this is why I like puffer fish.
You don't have to worry about the puffer
fish following you. The puffer just
always follows you. See, he's on the top
of my screen.
mummy.
Hobalt mummy
and a yellow light statue. Oh jeez.
Um,
I left the cat as well. [ __ ]
What do I have?
I don't have anything else to throw.
Oh
well,
that was easy.
Yo, dumb cat.
Get over here.
Now, this is why we have this
Did that go down or was it already poor?
And we got the mummy wrapping either
way.
See
getting steps on thing
thing is
this stupid cat. Yo cat,
come here.
I think you just need to get like a
tripe ration or something so it follows
you more closely.
Am I stupid or is there just like the
entrance is hidden? Screw you.
What is this?
A monkey.
Once again,
we have no way to proceed.
There we go.
Let us
pick this up.
I have AC4 right now.
Where's I?
Let's wear I
wear
I.
You cannot wear armor over a wrapping.
Okay.
So, let's just
take off
the wrapping.
And then let's
AC2
provides magic cancellation. one,
but we definitely want to put on
mummy wrapping again.
That was super worth it. AC2,
Giant ant
is dead.
The kitten falls through a trap door.
Uhoh.
I think we just find the next level
quickly.
And we just go down without any more
exploration.
I'm just trying to see if there's
anything super scary in here. I don't
have any potions that I know to be safe
or wands or anything.
I have good stats.
I think I go down one square
so they can't range me.
Okay,
we just keep hitting it.
If we get if we get out of this,
I mean, that's basically all the
equipment we'll ever need sorted. Even
if we lose the kitten,
we can go all the way back up to level
two for the altar with as much as we
could carry.
Full shaman is dead. That's one of the
more
dangerous things down.
You feel more confident in your weapon
skills.
I still don't fully understand how skill
advancement works.
you just get a point to put in whatever
weapon, right?
I don't know if we should save that. Try
to get like a long sword.
We can kill these, I think, unless
there's anything super dangerous in
here.
Okay, let's see what is left in this
room.
I have stealth, by the way. Uh, dwarf
king.
Wait, I am a dwarf.
Is it peaceful if I wake it up by
mistake?
What do we want?
Well, we definitely want the darts.
We want the daggers.
If I have to wait, I have strength 25.
Can't I just carry a ton of stuff?
I can take the potion
and the gem.
scimitar is 1d8
versus I have a spear
is 1 d it's d6 or d8
Oh, wait. Why did this just mess me up
completely?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It It I was typing in
the other window.
A K
N P
S U
here. Let's just do this from scratch.
We definitely want
this. This
we want the
may as well take the scimitars.
and then let's just see how many of
these helms we can carry.
Did I get a bow?
Valkyries use bow.
I see we have plenty of daggers then.
See,
leave the arrows
and we'll just take this big stack of
helms.
I only got one of them.
Anything I can drop?
Nothing heavy, right?
Yeah. Let's just be really,
really, really disciplined with this.
I'll try to do this quickly.
Monulus,
this thing just We should basically be
fine for a bit.
The leaportitis.
We definitely do not want that.
We'll take the potion.
Yeah, we're fine. We can kind of just
kill whatever for now.
Um
the issue is going to be
if we just keep killing everything on
our way up and down like we're going to
very quickly
not have some great AC here
56 health
level like six or whatever.
Let's just eat this thing.
Okay. Can Why is that immediately
rotten? Does anybody know? I've had this
happen several times where something
that I kill on the like the turn before
is just rotten immediately.
Now I'm blind.
We'll just go.
Actually, let's try to
What is this thing? Lykan.
Leave it.
Don't really care.
All right. So, this is what we are here
for.
Drop
everything.
H.
Uh I can the food even be cursed.
Okay,
that's not terrible.
We're low on capacity, so I think
Seriously, what is this, dude?
A bat die.
this thing.
Drop
this thing. Drop.
Drop.
That's it.
is scimitar better than spear?
I think slightly.
We have an uncursed orcish helm. So we
can
we can wear the helm
AC1.
Uh we also can do
our
Valkyrie has learned spear skill.
Do you know what happened to um
I thought Valkyrie started with a long
sword
cuz I actually don't know how to get a
good weapon now. I know long sword you
can dip it actually like next level
Okay, then.
Uh, Dom, that's you're probably not
going to want me to review something
that's heavily AI gen.
Let me just I'm going to look this up
real quick.
Shoot. It's also getting late. I uh I'm
having fun with this though.
Dwarven spear is really good. Oh, it's a
dwarven spear, right?
I forgot it wasn't a regular spear. So,
dwarven spear is d8. So that's the same
as a scimitar anyways.
All right, we'll level the spear skill,
I suppose.
Okay, let's go. Here's what we're going
to do. Let's drop
Yeah, this is not that type of game.
Ryan
Mall,
we're at AC1.
Uh yeah, it's [ __ ] hard is what it
is. So it's kind of crazy the agents can
do anything.
Scroll.
Oh yeah. So, I left these scrolls.
on half of what I've done here. Where's
the score option?
cuz your agents might do less than half
of what I've done here, but uh our
agents might be a little better. You
should ask Finn about that.
Yeah. I can't I know it's in here
somewhere. Oh, there it is.
A is shows score.
Oh, no. The Yeah, the agents do better
than this, man. 2,300 score. Yeah, our
agents are better than what I've done so
far.
Yeah, significantly better. Like I said,
ask Finn.
I think it is unfortunately worth it.
Right.
Okay, here's what we're going to do.
Uh, we'll just do a
armor
R
and then we will pick up
this.
How do I have a little trouble lifting
it when I just I just dropped one of
these things?
Oh, I know that this is barely
scratching the surface, man.
Ah, I see how I'm an idiot. Okay, drop
armor.
I'm going to go back here as quickly as
I can without messing this up. I think
it's worth it because there's a decent
chance that I get a um
an enchanted home here.
And if I have to play the next few
levels without a uh a pet,
then I definitely want to have like AC
zero
going in.
The hell is this?
Mains hobbit. Yeah, whatever.
Uh, where are we going?
Aren't we just going here anyways?
We're just going there.
And this is the annoying level that I
have to go super far.
Yeah, you need to be very patient
though. Like it is totally worth
it's worth me going up just in case one
of these helms.
See, this is why this is why I should
have my pet because then I could just
test these items quickly without having
to go all the way the hell up to here.
That
die.
Okay. Drop
items of unknown status.
UV wx
Cool. We have one cursed thingy.
A B C D.
And then we will drop
drop the
first scroll
and then we will start wearing some
stuff.
We'll try this one on.
Oops. Already wearing a helm. So I have
to do like
armor.
Um,
where
U
W
Unfortunately,
they're all exactly the same,
but we and just drop. Oops.
Okay,
retro ration.
I think we are good now to just like
continue.
I would have preferred to have AC
zero
by imp.
What the [ __ ] was that?
something.
Might as well go here while I
sw a rat or something.
Oh, yeah. This is a were
dagger misses the were rat.
Have anything else to throw? Got some
darts.
We also didn't finish searching.
Guess not.
This thing
a stiletto
corpse. Okay.
Stiletto.
Well, we don't know if this is a curse,
but we're not going to be equipping it.
We're just going to be using this for
throwing.
And we don't particularly have to care
about these guys. Oops. Unless I mess up
my movement, that is.
Uh, okay. Cool. We're back to the
correct level.
What is this rocks?
Um,
interesting.
I guess I'll take few of them.
I'll drop them if I need to
and just chuck them at whatever.
The important decision now. Okay. First
of all,
it
nothing here. Interesting.
Okay. The important decision now
large cobalt dwarf. Everything here
except
the dwarf king. I know we're fine.
I think he is peaceful.
So I think we can just like
Okay.
Um,
Dude,
why is this thing hostile?
the thing is I don't have any wands. I
don't have any of these scrolls
identified.
Elbert.
Can I write with an item under me like
this?
I think it's just engrave Elbert is the
only thing I can do. This kills me next
hit.
I either try to engrave or I just read a
random scroll.
I could pray.
What's the key?
Shift E.
So, that's so [ __ ] I looked this up.
I looked this up and it said that the
dwarf king would not be aggressive to me
because I'm a dwarf.
what you get for using an LM instead of
the wiki.
That was a very good run. Like a good
start.
No, that was like I just didn't know
that, man. I thought I thought that the
gnome king would not be aggressive or
the dwarf king would not be aggressive
because I'm a dwarf.
I thought randomly generated dwarves are
of every type are always
randomly generated dwarf kings are
peaceful towards dwarven and nomish
heroes.
Like dead to wrong information is kind
of shitty.
The wiki says it as well.
I probably could have just run if I'd
known that they were slower.
Oh, that's actually like half. I got a
5k score my first run and I got to depth
nine.
probably worth price IDing identify
scrolls.
cuz I had five potions of healing
without knowing it.
Yeah,
probably that
enchant armor, enchant weapon. All
right, we definitely need to price ID
some [ __ ]
We killed a ton of stuff because of the
room, the uh throne room.
Yeah, that's why I say uh I say it's
just that.
All right. Well, I mean that's good
timing. That's it for a stream. Then I
will uh go get some food and I'll
probably do some other stuff.
Um Oh, yeah. Hey, Ryan.
This is how we train Breakout and
Puffer.
Done.
All right. Well,
probably will stream a little bit
tomorrow or something. Uh, normal work.
Might play some more of this in the
evening after dinner. We will see.
I'm just trying to get a sense of like,
you know, what actions and obs does the
agent really need to have access to?
to be able to do decently here.
All right, thanks for tuning in, folks.
For anybody here for my normal stuff,
solonpuffer.ai.
Um, you can follow the stuff over there,
start the repo and all that. I get some
food.